i've been up tight lately all of my
friends have married
which is getting frustrating for me
because i'm single and like at the very
least i need to just hurry up and have a
kid because i'm like
three four years away from the gay
rumors you know
you hit 32 waiting for you to get to 35
you got to hurry up and do something
what sucks
is being the single friend because now
all of my married friends
expect me to lie on their behalf like
all the lies
flow through you i'm not lying to your
wife man that's the mother of your
children
even if you wanted me to lie like they
don't give me enough time to learn the
lie i got a buddy nikki in the bronx he
calls me five minutes before it's going
down
hey man she's gonna call you just say
shrimp scampi clint what
does that mean not enough time that's
not even a complete sentence there's no
action verb in that that
what's the scampi doing i just think
technology's ruined dating though like
if you're married now it's gotta suck
because
everything that buzzes and beeps that's
just one more thing to argue about if
it's a cell phone or
email passwords god forbid your phone
rings too late at night
who is that calling you that's late it's
11 o'clock it's pretty late too late to
be getting a call
it's my grandparents are still together
that's why old people stay
married because they met before stuff
was invented they didn't have to deal
with this crap like everybody thinks
it's true love that's what you always
say oh my grandma granddad had been
married 50 years
that's love no it's not your granddad
didn't have a facebook page with butt
naked chicks on it
so you didn't have to deal with that
crap
that's all it is even with the
technology they did have they couldn't
argue what did they do watch the radio
in the 20s you can't
argue about that i'm pretty sure my
grandma didn't go through my
granddaddy's telegrams when he came home
standing on the front porch mad who is
this girl who is eunice herschel
who is she why does she keep sending
western unions to the house the third
one is mighty latest four in the
afternoon
i just i wish dating could go back to
what it used to be like when there was
no technology i was watching a civil war
movie
these dudes were romantic these dudes
wrote letters you realize how heartfelt
that is like
these guys hand wrote letters there was
no pencil or pen these dudes
had a feather and a bucket of ink and
they dipped inside
no one's getting handwritten letters now
you're not getting a handwritten letter
from somebody unless they're in prison
that's the only way
you're worth somebody's time now you
know but you watch these movies these
dudes were coming from the heart it's
dangerous out here my love
the general has to be in the boys
station outside of gettysburg right now
the men are tired we're scared
not sure if we have enough rations to
make it through the evening
morale is low
tim timlin from akron lost his leg in a
cannonball explosion yesterday
and one of us has to tell his wife
janice what happened she shan't be happy
to hear that news
charlotte my love when a man is out here
on the battlefield and dangerous
surrounding him the only thing he can do
is hold this rifle
and hold it close thoughts of your love
envelop my soul and they sustain me
should i not make it back alive tell the
kids that i died a soldier sincerely
terrence
third calvary god you take that letter
this is what happens he takes that
letter he gives it to a dude on a donkey
eight months later
she gets it and she's cool like that's
all you had to do to be a good dude was
talk to your girl twice a year
that's it just write a letter you can't
do that now not with technology you let
somebody text you and you don't reply in
under 30 seconds
where are you i just sent you a text you
better reply to me
i know where you are i got google map
gps i'll find you around
i feel you [ __ ] i love you don't ever
leave me
[Applause]
wouldn't it be cool fellas if you could
just write your girl a letter you go
missing for
half the year no matter what you're
doing you just sit down civil war style
scribble something out to you
it's dangerous out here my love
me and the boys are down here in miami
beach outside of a strip club
the men are tired we're scared not sure
if we have enough one dollar bills to
make a video
morale is low
tim timlin from akron lost 10 000 on a
lap dance last night
one of us has to tell us wife janice
what happened
she shouldn't be happy to hear that news
charlotte my love when a man's in the
vip of an adult entertainment facility
and a woman's rubbing her naked body
against him the only thing you could do
was hold her clothes
thoughts of your love enveloped my soul
and nourish me
i hope that this isn't my last
correspondence to you but if it is
tell the kids that their father died
having a threesome
cavalry thank you very much